uh a bunch of you sent me um articles
about
this next story
and it shouldn't come as a surprise
but it should be extraordinarily
alarming because of what it means
the accounting firm which has
represented trump's business for a
decade
is now saying
we can't trust you can't trust i me
david pakman i can't trust
the
financial accounting records that they
put together for the last decade
because they may be based on underlying
fraudulent information
and the accounting firm has abandoned
trump and says they will no longer
represent trump's business this is
unbelievable
yahoo news nbc news reporting trump
organizations accounting firms says
accounting firm says it can no longer
vouch for financial statements from the
company
this is a major story
and it is not getting the attention it
deserves
the accounting firm mazars usa
said a decades worth of financial
statements from the trump organization
can no longer be viewed as reliable
according to a letter made public monday
by new york attorney general leticia
james as part of her civil probe into
trump's company
mazars also said it will no longer work
with the trump organization meaning the
company may have to get new financial
statements that could complicate its
ability to secure loans in a february 9
letter from mazar's group general
counsel william kelly to the trump
organization's chief legal officer the
auditing firm said its work from 2011 to
2020 quote should not be relied upon
in the world of corporate accounting
this is like a ground-breaking statement
of
there's some really bad stuff going on
here and we meaning the accounting firm
want to try to get the hell out from
under what might be coming in our
direction
uh they also added we write to advise
that the statements of financial
condition for donald j trump for the
years ending june 30th 2011 to june 30th
2020 that's fiscal years should no
longer be relied upon and you should
inform any recipients thereof currently
relying upon one or more of those
documents that those documents should
not be relied upon understand that that
is a signal to all of the lenders that
have given trump money on the basis of
these financial statements they
they're being told you made financial
decisions about the trump organization's
credit worthiness on the basis of
account of account accounting documents
that we the accounting firm are telling
you cannot be relied upon uh here's a
copy of the letter
sent out
uh dear alan this is to alan garton the
um chief legal officer of the trump
organization this and from the
accounting room dear alan it's like a
dear john letter we write to advise that
the statement a financial condition for
donald j trump from 2011 to 2020 should
no longer be relied upon and you should
inform recipients relying on those not
to
we have come to this conclusion this is
the best part we have come to this
conclusion based in part upon the
filings made by the new york attorney
general on january 18 2022
our own investigation and information
received from internal and external
sources they are saying in part
the investigation being carried out by
letitia james of new york
has brought to their attention
the
corruption
and
alleged fraud potential fraud i want to
be careful with how i say that
committed by the trump organization and
we already know what this relates to
this mostly seems to relate to the
valuation of assets
what michael cohen and others have told
us the trump organization would
regularly do
is you take a building let's say
we agree that in the real world the
building is worth 20 million dollars
when it comes to assessment for tax
purposes
the trump organization would say look at
this crappy building it's not worth 20
million it's worth 10 million dollars so
tax us
on the 10 million dollar valuation and
they would submit documents supporting
that that's what it's worth on the other
hand when the trump organization wanted
to get a loan using that same building
as collateral they would say listen
this building's not worth 10 million
this building's not worth 20 million
this building's worth 40 million dollars
and so you can give us you know if it's
an 80 loan to value or whatever the case
is you can give us a loan
on the basis that the collateral we're
offering you is worth 30 or 40 million
dollars rather than 20. and that would
encourage a lender to say
we can give them 28 million bucks
because if they default we take the
building and we sell the building for 30
or 40. when the building's only worth 10
or 20
giving a 28 million dollar loan with
that building as collateral obviously is
not a good idea for the lender so that's
the gist of what has been done
um other notes from the letter
um
due in part to our decision regarding
the financial statements as well as the
totality of the circumstances
we have reached the point such that
there is a
conflict of interest with the trump
organization as a result we are not able
to provide any new work product
to
the trump organization
um
this is an example
of rats abandoning
a sinking ship
and it's crimes all the way down
and consider
that
trump was elected partially on the basis
that he was a really successful
entrepreneur
and then we found out well he's had a
bunch of business bankruptcies but he
said that was him just using the tax
code to his advantage
this additional thing suggests that even
the degree to which his business was
successful
was based upon accounting distortions or
at least potentially on that basis and
when i hear you can't trust these uh
accounting documents and we're not
working for you anymore what i hear is
we committed fraud for the boss
and we're gonna get caught and we're
doing what we can to wash our hands of
him and i think
anybody who knows anything about trump
knows that cutting corners is sort of
the name of the game it's the status quo
and people continue to love the guy and
defend the guy but this is not looking
good at all in terms of this
investigation into the trump
organization will it ever hit trump i
still don't think so
and i know many of you get mad when i
say that but i don't think so let me
know if you have a different view on
that particular piece
one of our sponsors today is masterworks
masterworks makes it possible for people
outside the one percent to invest in
world-renowned art think picasso monet
banksy by letting you invest in shares
representing an investment in these
pieces art as an asset class has
outpaced the s p 500 over the last 25
years with almost no correlation to the
stock market which is a key indicator i
look at when thinking about
diversification masterworks analyzes
sixty thousand data points to decide
which paintings to acquire each painting
ranging from one to thirty million
dollars then they file a public offering
with the sec effectively securitizing
that painting there's always a wide
array of paintings to invest in so you
can not only diversify
into a new asset class you can diversify
across an asset class masterworks is a
really unique platform a very
interesting way to diversify against the
market craziness right now and if you
want to learn more about masterworks and
sign up use my link in the description
to get priority access